قال ناصر يبهر العالم بتقديم رونالدو
وغضب عراقي من احياء ذكرى قاسم سليماني
وعمل بطوله في السعوديه انقاذ طفل من سيول
جارثه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
اكيد رح نبدل لك حلقتنا اليوم بالحفله
الاسطوري الي صار امبارح في ملعب مرسول
بارد بالرياض لتقديم نادي النصر اللي
لاعبوا الجديد البرتغال العالم كريستيانو
رونالدو اللي شغل الدنيا والعالم من ايام
وبالفعل مثل ما كان متوقع الحفل كان
اسطوري والحضور تجاوزتين الف شخص الحماس
كان كبير
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا قبل الحفل كان في مؤتمر
صحفي لرونالدو تحدث خلاله عن حماس والخوض
هالتجربه وانه ليس من السهل الفوز باي
مباراه في الوقت الحالي لان الفرق باتت
اكثر استعدادا وكره القدم كانت صارت
مختلفه وانه غير مهتم لاي كلام يقال عن
انضمامه الى النادي اما لحظه دخول الدون
الى الملعب وهو مرتدي لخميس نادي النصر
لاول مره كانت تاريخيه ولا تخلو من الطاقه
الايجابيه اللي كانت كفيله في اضافه
التفاؤل والحماس والمحبه اللي كانت عنوان
الحفله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
التفاؤل والمحبه والقليف لحضور حفل تقديم
الدون كنج من نجوم العالم يتصدرت العناوين
لكثير من الصحف العربي لكن مصطلح الجنون
الرياضي وعباره الحفاوه والجماهيريه طغوا
على عناوين الصحف الاجنبيه التي يبدو انها
تفاعلت مع الحفل الكبير والجماهيريه
الكبيره التي حظي بها النجم كره القدم
البرتغالي في السعوديه وهو مرتدي قميص
نادي الجديد خلينا نشوف بعض العناوين
للسيطره على الصحف الاجنبيه
ومن بين الفيديوهات اللي انتشرت بشكل كبير
عن الحفل وحصل على ما يقارب المليون
مشاهده كان الفيديو دون وهو عم يوقع على
كره القدم
[تصفيق]
صلاح الدين
تستاهل يستاهل
تستاهل اما الفيديو الثاني اللي حصل على
اكثر من مليون مشاهده فهو كمان لرونالدو و
عم بيوقع على الكره لكن هالمره اهداها
بضربه حظ لاحد الجماهير
[تصفيق]
واكيد كالعاده ما كانت عائله كريستيانو
رونالدو بعيده عن الاضواء ولا عن حفل
التقديم ولم تقل حفاوه استقبالهم عن حقائق
استقبال لاعب نادي النصر البرتغالي
رونالدو
كريستيانو
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الي اختار كلمه العالم الي يعرف عن هويته
الجديده وهي تسميه نادي النصر الي صار نجم
[تصفيق]
وعن هذا الاحتفال الضخم وكواليس تغطيه
العربيه ووسائل الاعلام العالميه ينضم
الينا من الرياض مراسلنا عبد المحسن
الحربي اهلا بك عبد المحسن بدايه سنبدا
بالقصه كيف بلشت عندما العربيه انفردت
بالخبر
اعلان عن انضمام كريستيانو رونالدو لنادي
النصر خبرنا عن تفاعل الناس مع هذا الخبر
بالبدايه
نعم بالفعل العربيه انفردت حقيقه في الخبر
قبل حتى ان يعلن نادي النصر وكنت على تم
الاستعداد وقتها في للقيام بهذه التغطيه
وبدانا تغطيه قبل ان يعلن النصر
التوقيع الرسمي مع كريستيانو ذهبت انا
للشارع اسال الناس اثناء الهواء البعض
منهم كان مصدوم بعض منهم كان غير مصدق بعض
منهم كان حتى يكذب الخبر فااه حتى انا
شخصيا يعني كنت اقول همم نحن طبعا فردنا
بالخبر ونحن همم لدينا الخبر الاكيد ولكن
للجمهور لم يكن يصدق حتى كلامي اثناء
سؤالي لهم كانوا يتكلمون في العموميات
الكل كان غير مصدق في لحظتها فكانت لحظه
تاريخيه وظهورنا في اللايف قبل الاعلان
الرسمي لنادي النصر كان صدمه حتى على
الجماهير همم وهم بالفعل بداوا بتداول
الاخبار بعد ان ظهر الخبر على قناه
العربيه وهمم بداوا بالفعل ب- اا تداوله
بشكل واسع وبنقاشه وبانتظار التاكيد
الرسمي بالنادي النصر في كانت لحظات
تاريخيه قبل الاعلان الرسمي
الاعلاميه العالميه والعربيه لهذا الحدث
على المواقف الطريف
الكواليس يعني
في التغطيه كانت التغطيه ليست على المستوى
الاعلام السعودي او الاقليميه او حتى
العربي كانت تغطيه دوليه بكل ما تعنيه
الكلمه الانظار العالم كلها كانت متجهه
الى الرياض فبالتالي كان عاطي مع هذا
الخبر همم ليس فقط للمشاهد المحلي او
المشجع عن نصراوي المحلي المهتم بك كره
القدم انما كان الكل يتابعك عبر ال همم
عبر القنوات عبر وسائل الاعلام المختلفه
وحتى يتناولون الفيديوهات التي همم تقوم
بها او تؤديها فبالتالي كان كانت التغطيه
مختلفه وكان ايضا وجود وسائل الاعلام
الدوليه في كل مكان في المتجر في الشارع
في متجر نادي النصر في الشارع وحوالي
النادي ايضا كان وجود كريستيانو رونالدو
يوم الامس في الملعب همم
العالم مستمره لكل غير مصدق لبعض كان يريد
وكمان احدهم ياخد سيلفي معه
وحدا كمان جرب ياخذ سلفي معه
ايضا اعلاميين صينيين يحاولون ان يلتقطون
معاه
م
مؤتمر
في الجانب الايمن معتقدا ان التصوير انتهى
همم اخذ راحتي على الاقل مع هذا الاسطوره
العالمي ولكن تفاجات بين الصوره كانت
مقوله لايف وزملاء على طول ارسلوا لي في
الواتساب انه همم خلي كريستيانو يروح
ويكمل الحفله ما احنا فاضيين انك انت
عن التيشيرت اللي حصلت عليها كمان خبرنا
في المتجر الرسمي كانت الطوابير الانتظار
لثلاثه ايام
وكان الحصول على هذا التيشيرت صعب جدا
فبالتالي انك تحصل على التيشيرت رونالدو
في الوقت هذا يعني هذه خطوه لا لا احد
يستطيع ان همم ان يحصل عليها ولكن انا
للامانه لم احصل على هذا التيشيرت والحظ
وليست لدي انما اخذته وتصورت معه ورجعت
لصاحبه وحنضمي للطبابير حتى احصل على على
التيشيرت من المتجر الرسمي طيب
تفاعل رونالدو مع الاعلاميين السعوديين
والاعلام بشكل عام كيف كان باختصار
التفاعل في كريستيانو
في المؤتمر الصحفي بعض الاعلاميين كان
يقوم بترديد ايضا سواء كان السعوديين او
حتى من من الخارج بترديد حركه كريستيانو
الشهيره فكان مصدوم اثناء وجود هذا
المؤتمر وينظر باستغراب
وفرحه ايضا
لكريستيانو ايضا كان بعض الاشخاص كانوا
يقولوا لا رونالدو اي لاف يو فبالتالي
كريستيانو اااه تفاجا وتوقف قليلا وقام
ينظر الى همم هؤلاء الاعلاميين في الحقيقه
كل ما حدث امس يوم تاريخي اشبع ما يكون
بالحلم ان يكون كريستيانو ليس زياره خاطفه
انما يكون معنا في الرياض وفي فريق النصر
مستمر ان شاء الله الى همم الى سنتين بحسب
عقده همم
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
ونبقى في اخبار الرياضه اللي ايام متصدر
العناوين بسبب الاحداث المتسرع الي عم
تحدث حول هذه الايام الخميس تم الاعلان عن
وفاه اللاعب كره القدم البرازيلي الاسطوره
فيليه عن عمر 82 عام بعد اختراعه مع المرض
وامبارح تمت مراسم التشييع والدفن في
مدينه سانتوس وحضرت الشيعه اكثر من كلمتين
و30 الف شخص من بينهم الرئيس البرازيلي
بطبيعه الحال لولا سيلفا وكبار الشخصيات
من السياسيين وغيرهم وكان من بين الحضور
رئيس الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم
الفيفانتينو تعرض لحملك كبير من
الانتقادات السلبيه من بعد ما تم تداول
صوره سيلفي وعدد من زملائه الرياضيات
الملعب في المقر الرئيسي للفيفا باسم
اللاعب الراحل اسطوره
[موسيقى]
فصل قصير ونواصل الحلقه
اهلا بكم من جديد بالتزامن مع الذكرى
السنويه الثالثه الاغتيال القائد في الحرس
الثوري قاسم سليمان اللي اسمه ترند على
تويتر من امبارح ليست ذكرى السنويه ابدا
السبب حمل قادتها جيوش الالكترونيه
[موسيقى]
شهدت المدينه المنوره وعدد من المحافظات
التابعه لها هطول امطار غزيره غير مسبوقه
تسببت في السيول وامتلات المنصات
بفيديوهات لما شهد السيول اخترنا البعض
منها
[موسيقى]
ومن بين الفيديوهات
صعبه بتوثق الانقاذ مجموعه من الشبان
للطفل كان عالق في منتصف السيول واستطاعوا
انهم ينقذوا من الغرق المتابعه
وينضم الينا عبر الهاتف من المدينه منوره
العريف مازن جهني الذي انقذ الطفل من
السيول اهلا بك
خبرنا عن لحظه انقاذ الطفل وعمليه انقاذ
الطفل
عليه الصلاه والسلام سيدنا محمد عليه
الصلاه والسلام
الوادي
تعالوا شوف
وتوكلت على الله ولا اراديا غير انا واقف
عند الوادي
شفت اللهم صل على محمد ام الطفل في الجهه
الثانيه تنادي على ولدها
وتبكي
وولدها بنص المويه
السباحه
وامها ملقاك
اما بحمد الله نزول الوادي
والحمد لله على كل حال
هذا بعود لكونك يعني كنت تعمل بالقطاع
الامني
الحرفيه كان يعني في حرفيه بالعمليه
الانقاذ
خبرنا على هذه بسبب خبرتك يعني بهالموضوع
بهذا المجال
والحمد لله الله سبحانه
قدرني على
توازني بواسطه مجرى الماء ومع مشي بالمويه
اني اتمسك لي بحاجه واطلع منها
وتوجه للطفل مباشره
[موسيقى]
ووو تقريبا
شرب من المويه حق الاجراء لان جايب تقريبا
قبل مسافه يمشي مع المويه
مع الشيل
وفي
الحجر
السيلفي عليه وتمسك فيها
الحمد لله وقف بنفس الموقع الموضح
بالفيديوهات وانا جيت على نفس الموقع جيته
وتطمن فيه احد عنده
وهديته والحمد لله
وسيطر على الوضع اللهم لك الحمد
حاولت اني استرجع بالناس اللي حولنا
ينزلون انا اما حابب او ينزلوا لي شيء
دفي فيها الطفل لين ما يجي اما الدفاع
المدني ولا
يجيها مختصه
اثناء السيول يعني والامطار الكثيفه اللي
شهدتها المدينه المنوره الفتره الاخيره
خاصه
الامطار ما شاء الله تبارك الله
ثلاث ايام
ماشي يعني كل الاوديه كلها شعبان وكل
[موسيقى]
المناجع المويه
والله عندنا احنا شخصين يا شباب والامهات
الله يحفظهم
يا شباب نروح ندور الاوديه ونروح ندور
راسي
المدينه المنوره
[موسيقى]
ختام حلقه اليوم من تفاعلكم الى اللقاء
هلا هلا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]